[Music]
chicken picking is a super-fun and
extremely useful technique on the guitar
but it can be really difficult to get
under your fingers so today I'm going to
show you two exercises that will help
you refine your technique and get
comfortable with it so you can use it
all the time now if you're brand new to
chicken picking also known as hybrid
picking I've linked to a video in the
description that will show you the
basics so be sure to check that out and
then come back to this video now on to
the two exercises this first exercise is
only going to involve two strings your
flat pick is going to be activating the
g string and your middle or ring finger
is going to be activating the high E
string now you can choose either one
here because ultimately you'll be using
both so whichever one needs the work is
the one I want you to use we're gonna
start by just pinching those two strings
together again pick on the g string
middle or ring finger on the high E like
so it's a nice steady pitch
easy enough not terribly musical so
let's actually make it musical we're
gonna start by playing AG major scale on
the high E string okay so we're only
gonna be fretting the high E string that
g string is gonna stay open we're going
to start on the third fret of the high e
go ahead and pinch the two strings
together the fifth fret of the high e
the 7th the 8th the 10th the 12th the
14th and the 15th now you'll notice I
use my index finger to fret all of those
notes you don't have to in fact there's
no specific order or finger that I want
you use to fret those notes whichever
one you have the most control over
whichever one feels comfortable for you
is exactly what I want you to use so in
its entirety that exercise will sound
like this
[Music]
once you get comfortable with that again
you can use your middle or your ring
finger on that high e-string I want you
to actually stagger it so instead of
pinching the strings at the same time I
want your pick to fire on the G and then
pick up or pluck up with your middle or
ring finger on that high E string so
instead of a quarter note it turns into
a set of eight notes one and and you'll
do that for the entire scale again so
it'll go one once you get comfortable
with that the last step or tweak you can
make to this exercise is to give it that
extra country chicken pickin snap so
instead of simply plucking that high E
string I want you to dig into it a
little bit almost pull it away from the
guitar and let it slap back at the
guitar now I'm okay it sounds aggressive
I don't want you to be super aggressive
I don't want you to break any strings
but just that subtle difference in your
picking technique will actually give it
this tone that's really punctual it
punctuates the note and it sounds like
it's really breaking through so here's
what that sounds like again that's just
a subtle tweak and something if you want
to pull a little bit extra chicken
picking panache out of that exercise now
on to the second exercise the second
exercise is going to use your pick your
middle finger and your ring finger and
what we're gonna be doing here is
actually executing a banjo type roll
where your pick fires then your middle
then your ring and it's gonna be musical
I promise but I want you to get used to
this roll pattern first because it's
really gonna help train the independence
of your middle finger and your ring
finger aside from your pick so let's
start by actually fretting the fifth
fret of the d-string your pick is going
to be assigned to the D string your
middle finger the G and your ring finger
the B and what I want you to do just for
starters is do as fire your pick
your middle and then your ring
pick middle ring pick middle ring pick
middle ring pick middle ring that's not
the full roll yet I just want you to get
used to the fingers on the strings now
let's add a little bit of timing to it
so this is gonna be an eighth note roll
and I'm gonna count along with it and
there's a little hiccup at the end so I
want you to be aware of it same exact
fretted position same exact picking hand
position we're gonna go pick middle ring
pick middle ring pick ring that's that
hiccup I was talking about pick middle
ring pick middle ring pick ring okay and
if I count along with that you'll see
why there's that hiccup at the end one
and two and three and four and we have
to complete that full measure of eighth
notes hence that hiccup so now let's go
ahead and make this musical we're gonna
again execute AG major scale but we're
only gonna be fretting the g string so
we're gonna start at the fifth fret go
to the seventh go to the 9th 10th 12th
14th 16th and end up on the 17th it's a
little high up there but it's kind of
fun to get hit that high up on the
guitar neck so we're gonna execute a
roll at each of those fretted locations
like so so again 5th fret
seventh fret
nice
and
14th
sixteen
seventy
for extra fun if you want to descend
that you can do that as well from the
17th fret on down to the 5th and even a
little bit past that so you'd go to the
fifth fourth second
so there you have it those are two
exercises that will help you get
comfortable with chicken picking again
also known as hybrid picking and give
you some musical outlets for this new
technique and I think the more you do
these exercises the more you'll find
this chicken picking technique actually
unconsciously showing up in your playing
which is a huge win thanks for taking
this lesson today just by showing up
you've become a better guitar player and
for that you should pat yourself on the
back
and I want to know how it went so in the
comments below please let me know and if
you have any other chicken picking or
hybrid picking tips for your fellow
guitar geeks you can leave those there
as well if you enjoyed this lesson I
know you'd be a perfect fit for Tony's
acoustic challenge
Tony's acoustic challenge is an acoustic
guitar program like you've never seen
before
so learn how it can take your playing to
the next level go ahead and click the
link here in the video or in the
description below and don't hesitate to
request your invite today thanks so much
guitar geeks unite
you